savez vous reconnaître une politique
publique qui échoue lamentablement
c'est simple c'est quand l'argent
injecté provoque l'effet exactement
inverse à celui recherché initialement
et c'est justement ce qu'il s'est passé
avec le plan anti pesticides selon
france inter et la cellule investigation
de radio france qui a mené l enquête au
départ l'ambition était louable réduire
de 50 % l'usagé des produits
phytosanitaires en une décennie et
convertir au bio 20 % de la surface
agricole un projet lancé en 2007 par
jean louis borloo le ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque
nom de l'opération ecophyto 2018 sauf
que voilà en disant l'usagé d'intrants
n'a pas baissé bien au contraire comme
vous pouvez le voir sur ce graphique
l'emploi de pesticides n'a fait
qu'augmenter + 15% sur la décennie un
fiasco total et qui aura coûté cher aux
contribuables
non seulement ce plan de réduction des
pesticides va mobiliser 800 millions
d'euros entre 2009 et 2021 mais 400
millions d'euros de fonds publics
dépensés pour les mêmes raisons par an
se sont rajoutés à cette somme la france
aurait donc dépenser plusieurs milliards
pour réduire les usages de
phytosanitaires en dix ans sans tenir
cette promesse les raisons d'un tel
gaspillage seraient multiples certains
des dispositifs liés au programme
ecophyto n'ont tout simplement pas
fonctionné comme il l'aurait dû et
parfois l'argent a tout simplement été
détournés l'enquète rapporte que les
chambres agricoles ont utilisé les fonds
du programme pour financer des
organisations syndicales quand elle ne
s'en sont carrément pas servi pour
acheter des places de foot ou pour
financer des voyages d'études en afrique
du sud pour des élus et leurs conjoints
on imagine assez mal en quoi cela peut
permettre de réduire l'utilisation des
pesticides tout comme le fait de
subventionner des acteurs privés du
secteur des phytosanitaires d'ailleurs
le groupe invivo ainsi bénéficier de
plus de 300000 euros pour tester des
solutions visant à réduire l' usage de
produits de synthèse contre les limaces
mais dans le même temps le groupe
agricole a racheté plusieurs grosses
sociétés irlandaises brésilienne et
chinoise pour devenir l'un des leaders
de la distribution de pesticides dans le
monde des acteurs comme l'institut
français du textile et de l'habillement
et le centre technique du cuir ont aussi
obtenu une enveloppe pour travailler sur
des équipements de protection des
agriculteurs du matériel auquel on a
recours justement lorsqu'on traite les
récoltes bref manne d'argent public
dépensé de façon totalement
contreproductive on espère que les fonds
du plan france relance lancé il y a un
an pour soutenir la transition
écologique seront un peu plus efficace